- You posted this photo
recently, so I wanna show this.
Like this is throwback.
- [Mindy] Yeah, it is.
- Like is this when y'all
first started the show?
- Yeah, so when we first did "The Office"
I mean, this is so sweet,
the first two seasons of "The
Office," whenever it aired,
we would go over to someone's house
and we'd watch the show together.
- That's so cool people don't do.
- No, people don't do that.
And I thought that was normal.
But like Steve was like
the star of the show
and like you can tell by the snacks,
this is not a fancy party.
- Yeah.
These are my people with that
snack tray, I'm like cool.
- Just like pretzel sticks and everything.
And Angela, we just took turns throwing it
and there wasn't this idea of
oh my house isn't fancy enough
'cause it was Hollywood.
Like we felt so separate,
well the show is not that
glamorous or anything
when you watch it,
but I just, when I saw it,
I first of all, I was
like "Wow, that's so fun
that we did that" and then second of all
I was like Steve Carell is so hot.
(Kelly laughing)
I feel like he doesn't get enough credit
for being like kind of a babe.
- I'm gonna own this right now.
So, I have always thought
he was cute, right,
but he came here, and
it was for our first,
it was for the first--
- Premiere.
- Premiere, yeah, 'cause he
did the Kelly Clarkson thing.
- Of course, in "40 Year Old Virgin."
- This dude, hanging out back stage,
he had like a long, like
trench coat like thing.
He had all this salt
and pepper facial hair.
I was like "Okay."
(audience laughing)
I was like, what the hell
is happening right now?
Literally, the buzz the
entire day was how hot is
Steve Carell?
- Steve Carell.
Yeah.
- I was like, what?
Anyway, so I'm with you on that.